all right let's jump into the first
store we got here from timcast.com
everybody knows by now that roe v wade
has been overturned as well as casey
and uh in concurrence clarence thomas
wrote
basically opening the door to
overturning gay marriage the text of
scotus roe v wade decision opens door to
up and gay marriage justice thomas calls
gay marriage precedence demonstrably
erroneous
saying uh in future cases we should
reconsider all of this court's
substantive due process precedence
including griswold lawrence and
obergefell meaning those rulings are not
guaranteed to escape future judicial
scrutiny i'm going to stop right there
and ask will
break this down for us because some
reports were saying no no no this has no
bearing whatsoever on gay marriage
but it certainly sounds like clarence
thomas was like man we should we should
overturn those those wrongs so those
those reports are correct ultimately
like the underlying decision here in
dobbs does not actually implicate
necessarily other substantive due
process precedence so what is
substantive due process so think about
what is the due process guarantee right
it's you have the you know you know the
government can't take away your life
liberty of property without due process
of law and so most people wouldn't
understand that to mean oh due process
like procedural protections like they
can't take away my property without a
hearing and notice telling that they're
going to do it and a chance to appeal
things like that so that's
um that's what most people think of when
they think of due process however the
court in order to protect certain rights
that they felt were so
essential that no process would be
sufficient to justify
um your the government depriving you of
them they came up with this kind of
substantive due process doctrine that
was used to essentially create new
effectively create new rights um and
that doctrine has been used to protect
the right to use contraception um the
right to marry the person of your choice
etc now so then the question is okay
well roe was also based on this
substantive due process idea does
overturning rho mean all substantive due
process is dead
the answer to that is no
um basically if you read dobbs they
didn't oh they didn't say substantive
due process was wrong in the majority
opinion they said here's how you
interpret substantive due process and
it's basically like is there a really
robust historical justification or
tradition of having this right even if
it wasn't spelled with the constitution
and they said
that for abortion that's not true
they're just historically abortion was
routinely banned throughout the states
so there's not like a historical backing
for it but and but throughout the dobbs
opinion they're basically saying this
doesn't necessarily implicate any of the
other substantive due process rights
those have to go through the same
analysis we're not getting rid of
substantive due process entirely
but it sounds like clarence thomas
clarence thomas would want to but his
views are pretty idiosyncratic on this
point in among the justices like i
actually as a legal matter i kind of
agree with clarence thomas in the sense
that i think stuff to process as a
doctrine is incoherent nonsense but a
bad person i know but that that said
like
you know i don't i don't think you know
if you had a a court case to try and
overturn obergefell on the grounds that
substantive due process is should
incoherent and you would i think that
that would lose eight one can i ask
about the what about interracial
marriages how was that decided how was
the inter racial marriage question
decided in that same sense so i think i
think interracial marriage and again i
i'm i'm have to reach back because i
haven't read loving versus virginia
which is the relevant case in a while
but i think that's an equal protection
case and that's that's a distinct
doctrine right so kind of you know
substantive due processes some rights
are so important they cannot be deprived
of you no matter what equal protection
is people must be treated the same way
right you can't you know if if there is
an existing right you can't deprive it
arbitrarily to one subset of isn't that
the argument in obergefell um so i think
obergefell is like this weird mishmash
of both substantive due process and uh
equal protection because anthony kennedy
is not as was not maybe rest in peace or
no he's still alive
he just retired anthony kennedy
shout out
sorry he's still alive wrote a bunch of
really terrible like decisions from a
legal perspective i mean it's not even
like outcome i don't care he was more
conservative than not but just reading
his opinions was like reading a bad
writer like somebody who just wasn't
very smart and so you read his opinions
and they don't make sense well and so
oregonville was written by kennedy and
so it's not trying to leak uh precise i
think we're gonna need a supreme court
ruling legalizing cloning
so that we can clone clarence thomas and
then nominate him eight more times but
holy we got it we got a court we gotta
clone joe biden a bunch of times too to
try to keep stopping him from getting
out of the supreme court yeah that's
great and just berate him
you know from from a logic perspective
i'm reading clarence thomas and i'm like
what are you saying makes total sense
and then
i'm reading the the dissents i'm just
like on the gun issue and here i'm like
they have no idea what they're talking
about do they well i'm glad you're here
i'm glad you're making an effort to read
for more people of color
so do we owe ruth bader ginsburg a debt
of gratitude i'll tell you about this oh
yes do we say thank you rbg you know
what's even more painful we might owe
mitch mcconnell
he didn't just get the three you know
the three trump justices confirmed he
also stopped merrick garland
well let's
before i sit here and laugh and agree
with james on this one i'd actually
sheamus i know you you have a cake
you're celebrating this will you are you
you're uh are you happy to see ro
overturned yeah i mean i'm i mean i
think we've talked about this before
like i would consider myself like like
modestly pro-choice right i think that
we've talked about this i think you and
i agreed basically on that right but
you're both wrong man
right as a you know i i also come at
this from a lawyer row was uh
a literal abortion of a decision
on this one and i consider myself a
pro-life libertarian and i think that
you know all humans should deserve the
same equal protections equal rights
equal liberty and that the unborn should
be protected in the womb and that's
because libertarians believe in personal
responsibility number one so elective
abortions or heinous like we were
talking about before the show yeah but
you know but even in the question of
rape i mean you have to ask yourself you
know what percentage of people that are
alive today are
the result of rape how many of those
people are glad they're alive how many
of those people
would say i'm so thankful to be here and
then i'm glad that they decided to adopt
my little sister for example
and i hope she doesn't mind that i talk
about this but it's kind of an open
family thing she's adopted
my parents and
her family uh
they had to have a conversation to try
and get her this
the mothered and not to kill her
and then they said please don't do that
and then once she was born the mother
didn't want her gave her to the
babysitter
and
you know i remember being a young man 10
years old seeing my little sister for
the first time
five months old looking up in the most
beautiful brown eyes and saying to
myself i'm so thankful that she's alive
and that she's here and now i have a
little sister and i have a nephew mario
shout out to mario i love you so much by
the way he's an awesome nephew a great
kid and my family is more full and
complete because without adoption
and you know are we talking about
adoption we need to be talking about
adoption more we need to be making
adoption more easy legally it's very
difficult to do it it's almost like
buying a baby these days you've got to
be rich to go and buy a baby
but we should be talking about that we
should be protecting life we should look
at life as a consistent ethic and i
believe in a consistent pro-life ethic
not because i'm religious because i'm
not
but because i do believe that all humans
deserve the same individual natural
rights and they should be protected from
reasonable idea of conception
until
uh natural death so ian
as uh i don't think you're as
politically active as anyone else here
i'm curious are you happy to see roe v
wade over time well i got mixed feelings
um it's not making abortion illegal and
i think that's something people got to
realize it's just giving the states the
ability to choose i think that less
abortion is a good thing i don't know if
making it illegal is gonna make less
abortion it probably will in the long
run and i think late term abortions are
absolutely gruesome um yeah they're
barbaric
i mean you're you're a full-grown human
at like four months or five months
that's like a small human being at five
months you see it it's like
living and moving and all that stuff
but i i don't know i wasn't expect i was
expecting it once it leaked
i i still got mixed feelings i wanna
talk about the the legal implications of
this because i wanna know more and
obviously lydia is celebrating along
with sheamus i am over the moon about
this and i think one of the things that
i think people need to argue when they
talk about how uh the conservative
christians don't care about babies once
they're born that's an out-and-out lie
you know those pregnancy centers that
they're firebombing right now
those are the christian churches
response to abortion
those help mothers in need they help
people who need the kind of help they
give free ultrasounds they give free
clothing they give diapers they give
bottles they have shoes they teach
parents how to parent they have a
response it's a very real response so
don't take any of that argument from
them they're full of nonsense my my
position is is you know i sense before
the show rather dispassionate um
you know i grew up i think i you know
will and i agree on like a moderate kind
of pro-choice but it doesn't exist
anymore in modern politics it is
basically the left is pro-abortion
they're they're they're being asked
about late-term abortion and the
response from prominent democrats is
it's the woman's choice and i'm kind of
just like my attitude is
if the woman hasn't has a health issue
and the baby can't like she can't carry
the baby anymore but the baby is viable
meaning it can live outside the womb why
kill the baby and there's no legitimate
answer that i've received because i
don't think there is a legitimate answer
it's completely dismissive of the idea
that the state might have an interest in
the life of an unborn child yeah which
is an absurd position yeah so i'll i'll
say this one more thing too
considering how insane everything's got
in this country i don't know if this is
good or bad in terms of the rising
conflict but i'd imagine it's probably
it's probably better
that the states can enforce their own
laws
i feel like it may result in more
geographic hyperpolarization which could
be a bad thing probably is a bad thing
in terms of keeping this country
together but i'm also concerned about
the idea that
for too long you've had people who live
very different lives and very different
worlds are legislating for people who
live in in different ways and and and
this mostly is a view based on guns
because people in cities are like guns
should all be banned and then it's like
bro we had a bear on our porch a couple
months ago like i'm sorry dude you're
not taking my guns away and and aside
from that's like i know it's not an
issue of hunting or it's an issue of my
right to defend myself the people who
live in cities should i get it you're
not worried about bears i'm all but you
should be worried about murderers and
criminals because crime is skyrocketing
so look the people who live in cities
should not be passing laws that directly
change the way of life for people who
live totally different lives and then i
see bills like this and i'm like it's
probably better off this way yeah i'm
not super positive but so there's a
couple things i really want to say about
this you're mentioning civil unrest the
fact that this country's so polarized i
agree that there's a chance this is
going to increase polarization it almost
certainly will but i don't believe that
unity can or ever should come at the
expense of goodness beauty or truth i
believe that there are some things you
can't compromise on
i'll also say this
what the supreme court decided today was
not simply that states are allowed to
extend protection to the lives of unborn
children
they decided
that the thugs and terrorists who are
mobbing outside of the homes of supreme
court justices attempting to assassinate
them and kidnap their families and
firebombing pro-life charities do not
get to decide what law is in this
country that is a massive win for rule
of law and not as many people are
talking about that we'll explain that a
little bit because every single other
institution for the past several years
has been caving into the mob on
everything there was no serious
condemnation from any of our political
institutions or the corporate world over
the blm riots or the 529 insurrection as
we like to call it here that's right
there was absolutely no condemnation of
it no one was punished for it they got
away with it and in fact their goals
were forwarded because of it they mocked
the final president and they mocked the
president when he was forced into a
bunker because rioters outside of the
white house had breached through the
barriers after assaulting 150 federal
agents and setting fire to a church
and the response from the media was how
mean of it was donald trump to disperse
through those riders to go over the
church to have a photo shoot
how dare he and peaceful a peaceful
protest and so what we are seeing here
is the and i think we really need to pay
attention to this it is the first time
in the last several years that any of
our major institutions has stood up for
itself and said no we're not going to
let violent thugs tell us how to run our
country thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8 pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there